What is the best approach for a nickel allergy? Contact dermatitis with chronic allergies, right?
Across the nutritious food spectrum. Okay, I don't think anybody has a nickel allergy. So let's
let's address that first. Can you have a can you have a sensitivity to nickel? Yes, but it is usually
because you have a toxicity to nickel. So nickel is a heavy metal. It's that's what it would be
considered from a functional medicine perspective. I've had people with nickel issues because they
had a nickel plate. So I remember one patient years ago had a nickel plate in his face because
he was at a motorcycle accident or something like that. He had chronic headaches. We tested it
with kinesiology. He had nickel toxicity and there's really, I don't remember what we did for
I don't think we helped him because you know there's no you can't keylate that out if you got a you
know a you know seven ounce plate of nickel in your body. It's very discouraging so I you know
you'll really have to be careful when you do medical procedures that are putting things in your
body that could be that are potentially become very toxic. So yeah you can have a nickel toxicity and
not have a you know some plate of that nickel that'll plate in your body either you can have a
metal toxicity due to exposure. You've got it in a pool you got it in you know some chemical some
pesticide or something a lot of pesticides have arsenic or pesticides have other heavy metals in
them. That's how they work. And you're exposed to those things. I've had I have one person that had
lead and it's very serious. A little bit of toxicity and he worked at an airlines and was really
in a little bit of aircrafts like you know for his job eight hours a day. He ended up having to go
to bail or get EDTA IVs. He was so he was so skilled. But so heavy metal toxicity is real
and it is something that a lot of people need to address. I don't think it's an allergy but it's
a toxicity. An overexposure of it can cause allergic type reactions certainly can cause rashes can
cause headaches can cause all sorts of different things. It can cause damage to the gut which leads
this second half of this question with chronic allergies right across the nutrition with nutritional
food spectrum. So when a person does a food sensitivity test like we were talking about like a
Syrix array 10 and it become you know so if they have the Syrix the way that lab reads it is they have
a colombic greed which we do. They have any of those antibodies yellow which you have you know higher
quantity of those that normal and red which is very out of range. But a person has when you do that
tested you know 70% of the food is on the red and yellow spectrum. That means that
that means that they have antibodies to those foods but it really means that they have
very damaged gut. So so damaged gut what's that? Leaky gut syndrome. Well what's that? That means
you have permeability of the gut. Your your cells and your gut are supposed to be you know tight
together. And that that junction of those two cells in the gut are those are epithelial cells are
formed what's called a tight junction. Yes and it's not very creative in how they they've
been. It was called a tight junction but when that tight junction is damaged and what damage is it
chemicals, toxicities, poisons, GMO foods, use of antibiotics, use of you know exposure to
consuming dyes of colorings and you know chemicals in our food. I mean you name it. Then that that
tight junction gets damaged. So that's what's called leaky gut. So things get across the gut that
shouldn't get across the gut and when things get across the gut that shouldn't get across the gut.
Remember you have two ways to get rid of bad things in your body. You either kill it through the
immune response or you have to detoxify it. So when toxins get across the body they they have to be
detoxed through the liver and the kidneys through phase one, two, three and then what I've labeled
four, five, six, have to get out of the body and in doing so that's how you get rid of chemicals,
heavy metals like we were talking about poisons. But when foods get across in forms that should never
have got across which we are speaking about before like a larger peptide should never have got across
the gut order. The immune system can react and the immune system is basically like what in the world
is this? Let's make an antibody in order to kill it. Well can you ever kill a food peptide?
No, it's not a living organism. So if you have antibodies to peptides what it's going to do is
every time you eat that food again you're just going to cause this inflammatory response and when you
cause that another inflammatory response that's another way that you cause damage to the gut. So
it's just this cycle. It's this negative cycle that person let's say use glutinous in a sample.
They have antibodies to gluten or gluten peptides every time they eat it because more inflammation
causes more damage. Now they have antibodies to protein, dairy proteins. Now they have
to continue to eat it and continue to develop antibodies to other foods and more foods and more foods
continue to have more damage. You have to break that cycle so you have to start. If all you do
when you do a food sensitivity panel is you stop eating that food. You're missing the whole point.
You have to stop eating the food because if you don't stop eating the food you're just going to
continue that negative cycle of inflammation every time you eat that food but you have to heal the gut.
If you're not taking different nutrition to help heal the gut then you're never getting better.
So all you're going to do is you're going to eliminate let's say all the foods on the bad part
and then you retested three to six months and now you have antibodies to the foods that you were
eating the last three to six months because you never healed the gut. So you have to really work out
healing the gut. It's a process. It takes time. It's not for the fate of heart but if you aren't
willing to do it then don't complain about it. I'm sorry but that's just the way it is. So proper
testing. Get proper testing done. I know what you know where the damage is what you have truly
have sensitivities to eliminate those foods and then you know start doing things that are going to
help heal that gut border, help improve those tight junctions, help stop this inflammatory
process and break that negative cycle in order for you to get better. It's not really rocket science.
It's just a matter of doing the proper testing, finding out what's causing inflammation, finding out
what the triggers are, getting rid of those, calling things down, using some things to help
call the inflammation down and start healing. It's a process.
So I go through a lot of this in agonizing detail in our courses and I have multiple videos on a
lot of these different things about what do you have an autoimmune disease? How do you find your
triggers? How do you find the thing that's causing inflammation? If I have microglial primate,
what do you do to calm that down? What are the steps to do with that? When I try to break it down into
baby steps so that you don't get over well, but that's the whole idea of the courses. It has a lot of
education. I think the more you know the better off you're going to be in a lot of different ways,
the more you're going to know what to do. And I think there's benefit to knowing more so that you
don't get duped by some of these Instagram and Facebook posts and practitioners that try to
oversimplify and then all you need to do is take this supplement or that supplement and then
you get very discouraged because it didn't work. So and the things that work, it's easy to get
up down and get discouraged.